welcome to the podcast guys how's it
going doing well how are you good good
um all right Ryan so for those of our
listeners who don't know who you are
what do you work on so started a company
uh 5 years ago almost or actually just
over five years ago called Product hunt
place to discover new products you see a
lot of makers and and companies
launching their new apps or their new
products to the world and kind of like
Reddit or Hacker News you have people
commenting asking questions and up
voting what they think is most cool mhm
in dton um I'm Dalton I'm a partner at
ycombinator U I'm also the head of
admission
um so that's the selection process for
who we fund and I actually worked at YC
when product hunt was in YC and so I
remember it um from the inside uh kind
of what the story was were you there for
the interview I was not I did not
interview him nope do you remember who
it was uh yeah it was
Sam H who else was it it was such a blur
it was it was 10 minutes of just rapid
fire questions and I was like all right
anyway I can't remember who else it was
yeah anyway all right cool yeah so D I
think he has a question for you to start
it off yeah so maybe to start with like
because I remember it so well um from
being there walk me through from the
formation of product hunt into applying
to YC and getting into that interview
that is already a blur you you're not
sure who's
there be was I there I don't even know
that's a very common thing by the way
it's almost like an out-of- Body
Experience you'd be people don't
remember them that well uh so it's not
just you this I hear that I hear that a
lot
where they there's a lot of anxiety when
you go into it frankly and and you know
you try to well someone gave me this
advice actually during YC is before you
do anything like that before you do a
pitch pump your chest physically it
might have been Kevin hail that said
this yeah I could be wrong so sorry
Kevin if if I'm putting words in your
mouth but there there's a step where you
can like pump your chest physically and
that act of physical nature of like
doing something that feels like a little
bit aggressive can Inspire some
confidence and uh you know it's actually
I may have done that a few different
times you know throughout my career I'm
not going to lie I've never heard that
advice before but okay that was Jordan
Peterson's first rule in his book it's a
stand up straight with your shoulders
back anyway all right uh okay so you
blacked out during the interview
basically uh but yeah what else was a
process like yeah so see where can I
start um so product time I'll do the
beginning really really quickly it
started off as a side project and it was
right between startups I was leaving
another one and kind of tinkering and
interviewing at other startups uh
started product on it started off as an
email list got some traction there that
then turned into a website and we looked
a lot a lot of inspiration like Reddit
and Hacker News and other communities
and like how do you what systems uh do
we want to take inspiration from how do
we want people to engage and so we we
built that that got some traction and
it's probably four I want to say four
months after the email started and when
the website was kind of operating it was
still a side project it was not
Incorporated it was still like a a thing
I woke up every morning super excited
about and found my mind continually 247
focusing on it but I still didn't know
what we wanted to turn it into and then
it was around the 4month time period I I
actually got a DM from Nicholas from
agolia they were in the previous YC
batch and I interviewed them oh nice
that was that was a good pick they're
doing well uh he dm'd me and said hey
hey Ryan uh you know a lot of people in
YC are are using product hunt they're
they're launching their products there
Gary tan would love to meet you have you
thought about joining YC and it was the
perfect time because I was sort of at
that crossroads where I'm like what do
we do with this you know we could keep
doing it as a side project we could uh
make it a company if you make it a
company how do you how do you build uh
do you raise money do you not so a lot
of lot of questions so I initially said
oh I'd love to meet Gary uh we went to
the Grove on I think Mission Street and
my questions for Gary were pretty
transparent I was like hey Gary
this is working here are the numbers I
love doing this but I'm not sure I want
to take VC funding and I'm and if I go
into YC if we do YC does that mean we're
on that path and uh Gary Gary said
something along the lines of like well
when you strike lightning in a bottle
that doesn't happen very often and I'm
and I say that not arrogantly it's not
that like product's the most amazing
best thing in the world it's not um but
very few times in your life do you build
something that is like wow there's
something there that is true and that
advice stuck with me and and Gary was
not ever he would never pressured me to
say you should do YC or you should raise
VC funding but that that advice or that
feedback was really insightful because
he's right it's like is am I ever going
to have a time in my life where I build
something that is starting to show some
sort of traction that's something that
people want ultimately do you remember
what the growth rate was when you
applied to YC yeah we if I'm not
mistaken I think we were like 50% month
over month um and that's not counting
like with 100 users in month one but it
was like over the course of a few months
with some some users and so it was and
actually going into the the interview um
I'm fast forwarding a little bit but we
we found out some things that worked on
the growth side and a lot of it was very
manual me basically emailing makers and
Founders and tweeting at them and I
found out that when I messaged them they
would join the conversation they would
share and that would drive more traffic
to the site and so there's a nice
flywheel effect that still exist today
and when I discovered when we discovered
that I was like well shoot let me just
do that more often and let me do that as
as fast and as quickly as I can going
into the interview so that I can say
honestly in the interview yeah we have
50% month-over-month growth in the past
like three months and uh and so anyway
that was having those types of metrics
gave me a lot more confidence uh you
know I didn't have to put my or maybe I
should have uh but I didn't have to pump
my chest to feel confident going into
the interview even though it was um kind
of anxiety inducing because it's such a
quick process yeah I I've had similar
conversations with folks like the one
Gary had with you and sometimes what I I
do is actually discourage someone from
doing Venture financing um if they have
a side project working especially if
they're making money and they never will
have like they can support themselves on
it and they can basically have the job
forever and you have this like cool
Freedom that so many people dream of I'm
sometimes like hey like keep doing that
like like you you're living the dream
the grass is not greener on the other
side um and if you do want to decide to
raise money um um just make sure you're
doing it for the right reasons that
you're really excited about it not
that someone told you to or you're
seeking approval from from Authority
figur you know what I'm trying to say
like you wanted to come and so what it
sounds like what was good in your case
is you were like very on board um versus
again sometimes you see people being
pushed down this path where they have
something working and then they they
regret it in the future because they
give away a good job right or a good
lifestyle I mean it's this weird thing
right where you think like startup
equals software right so like because
I'm making profitable software therefore
it is a startup but it can equally be a
small business yeah semantically you can
call it a startup too I just maybe it's
like the VC Line in the Sand it's not
for everybody and especially like I
really respect there's so many great
Indie software developers building like
mac
software and like they make a good
living and
like yeah they got I think they have a
lot figured out that other people don't
and so those people I'm like yeah I
don't know if this is I think you keep
doing what you're doing yeah that that's
that's the the thought process that went
through my head and so there there was a
scenario and I was trying to imagine
well let's see if first off I didn't
have much sin savings and I'm not an
engineer and so that was one of the the
things is well I need people to help me
to build this thing and build out you
know this road map that I have in my
brain and and so one way to do that is
you get money to pay them well how do
you get money you could do it through VC
or you can you know make money in the
product itself um you know there's other
other means to get money um but I was
certainly evaluating well what if we
never raise VC money what if I could
pocket $20,000 in my pocket per month
100% of the business that'd be amazing
and isn't that what wire cutter did do
you know do you know the wire cutter
folks is it didn't they bootstrap it off
the affiliate links and yeah never
raised a is that right yeah they it's
possible I don't know if Brian and team
raised maybe they did it friends and
family certain but they never raised
like a real like VC full round yeah and
that was 30 million New York did very
well um yeah he did very well yeah and
and even look at what Gabe's done with
with tech me which has been around
forever you know it's it's been it's
it's basically a force and like a thing
that everyone in technology knows about
it every day yeah con it doesn't he
hasn't raised money and if he did raise
money the product would change
dramatically they'd have to figure out
um they'd have to figure out a lot of
things to change it from what proba have
to throw conferences that would be my
guess I've actually talked to him about
this so yeah I don't think that would be
his first choice but uh I don't think G
doesn't seem like the conference kind of
guy it does
not this is this is a little bit of a
tangent but what did you think of when
Indie hackers started to come up because
that was a little bit after product hunt
and it's very similar and it's within
this exact Niche yeah yeah I've been
thinking more and more about in my head
I describe it as like maker communities
and I would put um you know prant in
that category Indie hackers lpath um is
certainly one of those and a bunch of
others and these are sort of communities
that are designed and some of them are
verticalized around a specific uh uh
function or whether it's like dribble
for designers stack Overflow for
engineers and or it's demographic based
like lpath for women and there's like
this whole ecosystem of maker
communities on the internet and I find
it really fascinating because it's it's
largely builds into the thesis of
product tun which was always well I love
discovering products there's uh like
this cultural relevance and interest
Within products and technology and more
and more people are building products in
fact in five years we're going to see a
ridiculous number of products being
built partly because it's more
accessible it's easier you don't
actually need any money to build
anything anyone with the motivation and
and internet access can like build
something so um I'm going off on a
tangent a little bit now but I I see IND
hackers is is certainly feeling this
sort of niching this Focus around like
bootstrapped entrepreneurs and that's
like their focus within this kind of
maker community ecosystem for me and
what courtland's done is is great I've
uh you know I've participate in the
community I've been on this podcast I'm
seeing him tonight actually um which is
funny um yeah I love what they're doing
um okay but but not all companies that
go through YC ultimately raise money
afterward right like zappier is a good
example that is correct yeah right and
so and they predated product hunt right
so I think kind of what Dalton was
alluding to like so you had this like
point where you could have raised money
or could have not raised money and so
demo day like why do you decide to
follow that path yeah so the the the
story with with us going through YC so
we we raised uh around around the same
time we got into YC and part of the
strategy was one we're building
something for the tech community and
strategically it was important or or
rather beneficial for us to get a lot of
notable tech people involved so we rais
money from uh like GV Greylock uh SV
Angel they were the first check in um
bunch of other like strategics and um
and having them involved was just
helpful to have like the support
community
and granted we probably gave up more
Equity than we needed to we raised a
million um before like going into YC
before demo day when we were targeting
like 400k but we got great people around
us and and then fast forward through
demo day um Mark andreon reached out
kind of in the middle and he'd been
following it and was interested and we
met up and and that happened and then
three or four weeks later he contacted
again and this was pre-demo day and it
was it was sort of uh you know how how
are things going and I knew what that
meant um you know they were interested
and long story short they ended up doing
a a series a like preemptively we were
pretty early especially for in snorts to
do that that type of round but the the
metrics are great the the vision or
rather the the opportunity massive and I
felt that it was it was better to uh you
know work with a great firm and raise
more Capital now than risk in six months
raising with maybe not as good of a firm
with maybe not as strong of numbers and
that money when would allow us to
continue for several years you know
building the company and hiring and and
building out we want want to build and
so I think my perspective working at YC
is your experience was 100% a side
effect of the lightning in a bottle
effect you had and is not at all
representative with 98% of the people in
YC that is just not how it happens and
the reason is people don't have Buzz or
excitement and because you're a
community they were participating in the
community and so it's very hard in that
era you know everyone was using your
site and so you see these things
sometimes when there's social products
that take off um everyone is on them all
the time I mean I'm not going to yeah I
can think of where there was like big
things that were hot and then everyone
got excited about them um but like it's
it's fascinating hearing you say that
cuz like seriously that is no one's
experience like that is like 1% of the
batch has that experience and the other
thing that I would say is
like those aren't always correlated with
the companies that like do really well
in the long term I'm trying to say in a
nice way but like when you see these and
it's usually cuz someone has like a hit
on their hands and so all the investors
like circle around and do all this extra
work to do it but if you look at like a
great example I like to talk about is
coinbase like he couldn't raise from
anyone I think he got like half a
million bucks yeah is that 2013 uh
winter uh summer 12 summer 12 oh wow
there's companies like coinbase where
like they couldn't get people to return
their phone calls and like couldn't I
think couldn't put together that much
money um and you know like as a
long-term investment wouldn't you love
to be an investor in that I you know
like that was like I think the price was
pretty good and so we so what we see
from our side of the table in YC is
like excitement around the core product
or or feeling like other investors are
excited about it and things like that
definitely give a Founder like yourself
tons of Leverage um but that I actually
have learned to not take that too
seriously as an investor as a signal for
how the company will do it's more just
like oh you know like people like
Scooters or something you know there's
other examples of these hype Cycles
happening um and to try to like remember
that it's the long-term things that
really matter like retention and growth
and revenue and those are those are
super predictive at demo day so so
anyway I just like I remember that too
when you were everyone was like so
excited about product hunt and everyone
wanted to work with you and they put
tons of work into it um and like like
yeah other Founders probably were like
why can't I be that like yeah I think I
think part of the challenge is is you
know some of the best investments are
somewhat contrarian so coinbase being a
great example in 2012 you know crypto
and that whole world was just like a
totally different era yeah and uh you
know the best investments often times he
was a single founder at the time right
was yeah he was a single founder oh
really when he was a Dem yeah yeah so
it's like Brian Armstrong like just
Brian yeah and it was like cool like I'm
the Bitcoin guy and I it's just me so
like he had a lot of it was not a slam
dunk at demo day for for coinbase and
it's it takes some conviction for like
the future the people that did invest
saw a future of crypto and what it could
become and so they they placed a bet on
him and that's that's where I think
maybe it gets challenging is if it's
already super hot then there's probably
also a lot of other companies competing
for that same real estate and I think
maybe product is probably not the best
example cuz we're not uh it's not like a
lift in Uber situation it's not like we
have a zero sum game when it comes
competition with other other companies
but um yeah I think that's that's true
uh and I've seen you know there's some
I'm trying to think back on the batch in
who's who's yeah who what what were you
summer 14 summer 14 yeah yeah so I think
uh
genko is Extreme like they probably have
hundreds of employees they're they're
they're a biotech company again like I
think they raised fine but there was not
this like hot Buzz oh Geno bioworks
they're from Boston they're you know
they're doing synthetic biology yeah
like like I don't think Mark HRI was
cold emailing them um and so like who
else was in summer 14 um there were the
nuclear companies remember the Octo and
the like the fusion and the fision
company were in summer 14 um so there
was like stuff like that but it it would
be easy to forget and this is also why
what's fascinating working here man is
people think that YC funds consumer
companies and this is what our bread and
butter is and like yeah like I think
it's like 5% consumer yeah it's funny
produ people think that most of product
hon is actually consumer as well it's
probably I don't know 50% at most is
consumer there's a lot of B2B stuff on
there well I mean they're just the
loudest right but that's what I'm saying
everyone remember oh product H that
makes sense like Reddit like Dropbox
Airbnb but man if you actually look at
the data which is my job to do um a huge
percentage is like good oldfashioned B2B
Enterprise there's a lot of hard tech
these days um and people just don't
think about them and it's not because
they're not good businesses just they're
less fun to talk about then and they
just don't maybe like I don't understand
biotech like I it's it's less exciting
for me simply for that reason because I
just don't understand it and you don't
know where the Market's going right
where like when you think about Airbnb
you're like oh I could see myself doing
that and then you just start doing it so
I'm curious D about application
surprises on your end because I think
like both of you guys having done
Investments as well you can understand
like the market gets like really frothy
and you're like maybe I don't want to do
that deal and I have to be principled or
maybe you do do the deal and that's how
it goes MH what were the companies that
we like I don't know about this and then
they went on to be like quite
successful um well there's a lot of
famous cases of people that we fund and
then that end up pivoting into something
wildly different and that ends up being
pretty good and so my my example that I
had a front row seat for was brecks um I
funded them to do a VR headset thing and
I was I was credit card company yeah
well I didn't know that and they I was I
interviewed them I was a group partner I
was their main contact through the whole
thing
and you know they
um they didn't know a lot about VR
headsets I think they like and you know
it sort of came out during during the
batch and during office hours that you
know perhaps they might want to consider
something they knew more about and they
had prior built something sort of like
strip for Brazil when they were younger
um and so the idea was like hey maybe
you should work on a some fintech stuff
that you that you know more about and it
was like well what should the product be
I'm like well what can you sell to
people in your batch like you should
talk to people what do they want oh like
and so the credit card thing just kind
of came out organically um and that was
like six weeks before demo day wow and
so there is there's no way you could
have known that the folks working on the
VR headset idea that didn't know much
about Hardware um were going to end up
being a pretty good company yeah um so
you were just surprised you like the
caliber of them as engineers and right
place right time and you know like
there's lots of people that that are
super high caliber but that was one
where certainly there was not a lot of
hype about their VR headset idea and and
they could have just gone all the way
through it and I don't I think it would
have been a struggle do you remember
what that conversation was like cuz I
think this is a it's a super common
question we get for the podcast people
who change their ideas what were those
conversations like with them what was
the progress looking like did they even
have a product they did not um I think
they ran into some pretty fundamental
issues that they they didn't know how to
fix and they didn't know how to get
around them they they hit a roadblock
and I definitely did encourage them to
maybe in a very nice way to maybe like I
always encourage people if they're
thinking about maybe pivoting to go more
towards something they're deep experts
in that they know more about and not
less about right and so you knew all
about Community like you were in the
right place for you and you still are
right so you you want to find a good
like cohesion of a Founder doing
something that plays to their strengths
sometimes people pivot into stuff that
they know nothing about and I'm pretty
sure that is not correlated with success
yeah it's yeah it's like if you tried to
Pivot into biotech yeah you be like oh
like biotch seems Co don't fun me um
yeah product hon is is like product is
me in many ways for better or worse and
it's it's just what I love I love
products and it's what me and my friends
were doing it so it felt it was just fun
and actually I I tend to when I talk to
Founders who are people who want to
start a company sometimes people
overthink it they're like I need to
start a business and I need to think
about markets and everything and I'm
just like change your frame of mind
think about it as an experiment or a
side project and when you put your your
frame of mind of like a side project
first you you start to you sort of
settle most people start to settle in
well what would I want to build or what
would I what could I use and it's just a
lot better way to start I think
personally so do you think there's a way
to play it over again where you could
have should have would have monetized or
expanded faster cuz again this is
especially if we're talking about
non-venture funded things it's not like
a choice if you're bootstrapping about
whether or not you charge for your
product right um and so just like where
would you advise yourself you know say
you have a time machine you could advise
your younger self what would you have
told yourself around monetization or
would have been like you know what
wouldn't change anything like that's a
valid option it's yeah it's one of those
things because I there's a lot of
mistakes I made of course and and so I
when I think about the mistakes I think
well I should have done it differently
and then there's another part of me
though that thinks well with the
information I had at the time I probably
still would have made the same decision
so the it is I don't think things would
have changed and it's also hard to know
if I did that would that have actually
been worse than what happened and
totally fair so the things that I I I
think we made a mistake on that I I take
responsibility for are a few different
things one of them one of them is we
should have dedicated a little bit of
time and focus on revenue and in the
beginning before we were funded we were
you know I was paying the heroki bill
out of my own credit card and it wasn't
expensive like a couple thousand doll a
month maybe at one point and I was like
well I don't want to pay this so let's
like do job ads and so we did job ads
made like $44,000 a month so not much
but like there's clearly like very easy
money like with our community it it
wouldn't have taken much work to make a
little bit of money to increase our our
Runway ultimately the challenge is
always especially with consumer kind of
focused startup is as soon as you start
making money then VCS will start judging
you based on that Revenue today and so
strategically there's some challenges
there which is an unfortunate byproduct
of I think of how a lot of investors
think um yeah for what it's worth I
would always tell someone like to make
that money like I wouldn't judge someone
for having small amounts of Revenue um
yeah I like if this was in someone's
application they're like yeah we're
making this money from job ads that
would be like cool like makes very smart
like I would in no way um cause me to me
less psyched about the company if I read
that in like an application or something
yeah I mean I'm trying to think of a
scenario where that would be hurting
their company like maybe if it was
affecting growth negatively somehow
right like giant banner ads for jobs I
feel like in a lot of media companies
what people end up starting with is
Affiliates um and so certainly that's
how wire cutter works is like if you
click on the thing you buy it on Amazon
they get like 3% and it is very hard to
build a huge huge huge company doing
that but it certainly helps when people
are doing communities or things around
Discovery right that's a pretty tried
andrue way to pay the bills yeah um yeah
yeah I think it's there's there's a
difference between like a job board but
then if if VC's if investors perceive it
as well that's that's the the business
model and that's the mechanics of how
you're going to make money and if it's
not impressive then they'll be
potentially less excited it's this weird
it's this weird game um that you have to
play um so one thing would be make money
uh extend Runway and and start proving
out some ideas early because taking
making money takes a while we we focused
on that last year and now we're
profitable yeah and so that was like our
number one goal is just you know let's
let's cover our cost and and that just
took a while took a lot of
experimentation to get there and to push
on this again I'm just picturing back in
the batch you kind of could have gone
deeper on products like really deep on
just Tech products and done like I don't
know partnership there's ways you could
go deep on that I remember there was
ideas to expand to discovering other
kinds of things and like you can
discover game I I don't remember the
current status of that feature but games
is one of those talking about
diversification about the kind of stuff
you discover that's one way to do it the
other thing you've done is use the
traffic you have and boot
um things like a job board or there's a
scenario where you literally could have
become angelist right like you could
have gone really deep on that and so I
can I can like it's your company but I
could pitch like five different
scenarios where you could have sort of
zeroed in on what you were most excited
about as a founder and by going deep on
those it would become more evident if
you know those are all wildly different
companies I just pitched but from that
lightning em bottle that you had you
could have like gone deep on one of
those and it seems like
your decision was to stick with the core
tech product thing and you wanted to be
really thoughtful about your community
and I remember there's some redesigns I
don't know like walk me through how like
when you had all these options on the
table strategically how you decided what
was exciting to you and what was like
yeah we're not I don't want to do a job
or that sounds horrible which is a very
good you know I think I would agree with
you of that statement but you could have
yeah yeah I we could have made very
easily like 30k or something at some
point you a mon without disrupting the
user experience for that you know we so
I do remember the slide that presented
at demo day actually with sort of the
long I think it might have been the last
slide which was like the Future Vision
which was okay we're starting with tech
that's like our core longer term we want
to expand to gaming I'm actually from
the gaming world before all this and so
I've seen the challenges of game
Discovery for consumers but also for
people making games and steam yeah you
could have done indie game Ste you know
like like a platform agnostic steam kind
of community actually that alone is a
huge bus on its own fashion and like we
even I love music I love discovering
music like that's even an area so we
were thinking initially at one point
like let's let's build up really really
amazing Community initially and then
let's expand and replicate this model
across multiple vertical and that
actually still to me is super exciting
and like yeah I was so like I remember
the slide I was like wow I'm like I was
convinced right this is defin like
because you had this initial kernel it's
so hard for Founders that start where
they can never get traction on the first
product then you can't be creative but
you had you had this like excitement and
kernel and capital and so like I was
like super excited I remember the demo
day I was like man I remember talking to
you in like the green room or something
like man I'm like super excited like
this is like you know like I just
remember being really excited on for you
and like being like this is yeah like
well there's I don't foret I forget what
I exactly said but it was like I too but
I remember seeing you in the Green Room
yeah and and everyone has like you can
imagine vend diagrams everyone is is
interested in multiple things like I
love music and I love games I love Tech
that's like my V diagram someone else
might love fashion and beauty and Tech
um and so the idea was like let's take
all these circles and like slowly expand
to like every kind of product category
and the the learning though there's a I
I was a little bit naive I think in
thinking that we could quickly replicate
communities in these different vertical
and the the nature of even just game
Discovery is quite different than
product and Tech Discovery and so in
hindsight we we tried to expand too
quickly in the beginning we didn't
properly build like a core solid like
Gaming Community that was the first
vertical we moved into we did gaming
then we did books and then we did
podcasts yeah because podcasts also
suffer from a discovery and Community
problem um and that a very common YC
application idea really podcast podcast
everything but definitely podcast
discoveries in there people send it to
me every batch what do you think of this
idea like reference every other dozens
of companies um very common very very
hard um and so yeah we we learned what
happened is we ended up having almost
the entire Community was still focused
on Tech and there their frame of mind
for using product was tech and and Tech
products and what resulted in in just
very little engagement in these other
kind of side communities and we were
unsuccessful in getting them spun up to
be like their own Standalone like
Community where people could you know
find the best games or or really visit
on a daily basis for that type of
content do you think you have a template
now of how you may have done that in the
past like the right people to hire maybe
even create a new like name it's not
called Product hunt anymore yeah yeah we
T we internally talked about like game
hunt and like expand even buying
hunt.com and like expanding out that way
and kind of making it more general
purpose and I think this is one of the
questions where it's in hindsight I
would love to see how this play would
play out but I don't know if it would
work yeah and one scenario is we would
build out separate domain entirely and
what that would afford us to do is
create an entirely different experience
designed for gaming which would be more
visual more videos more imagery uh it
might well it would require people to
have better ability to focus in the the
platform that they use whether it's
mobile or Xbox or Playstation or whatnot
and that's a very different experience
in browsing I feel like you're so good
at Community I can just picture you
could have used like really cool video
reviews or you would have had like the
equivalent of the maker like I I can
like see it right like I guess it's part
of my job but like just you describing
them like yeah that would be very
different than all the other video game
Discovery things and like that sounds
really useful yeah right there's nothing
like that right now and and still like
somebody should build it um what we're
now focusing on is actually doubling so
that was one horizontal approach go
really wide build you know a network of
properties potentially uh instead what
we focus on is let's go deep because
actually as as big as this is this is
also really big you know focusing
entirely just on technology because who
doesn't have an iPhone first off or like
an Android phone you know there are some
people in the world but like more and
more people are adopting just a
smartphone in their pocket that alone
every person that has a smartphone in
their pocket could be user or product
hunt doesn't mean that we've designed an
experience for everyone today but the
market opportunity and and uh you know
the influence of technology is
increasingly growing so we've we' sort
of honed in and I don't know three years
ago probably honed in on that that
direction and said let's go deeper into
technology and focus on that vertical
and focus on our bread and butter
instead of trying to spread so thin yeah
I mean so going deep there like
sometimes people go up Market where
they're like okay we'll also do this
thing for Enterprises and you could have
helped people discover
enterprise software and man that sounds
super lucra again so like I can't help
but like brainstorm of the stuff so I'm
just thinking through you know back in
the day when you had everything lined up
and ready were there things that you
could have been excited about that were
not selling out your vision of what it
could be but that would have like
allowed you to to go super deep on this
because again you have resources now but
it's a different setup than if you were
like trying to build a company that you
know could employ a people or become you
know future of everything yeah so one
thing that was suggested early early on
by a few of our investors CU they're
they lend as as an investor and
investors were using product hunt to
find and stay updating what's cool yeah
and a few few different investors and
people suggested hey you should start a
prodon fund yeah you should build a fund
on top of protaton invest in use the
data in the community and everything to
source and find really early stage
opportunities and I was pretty adamant
as as tempting as it is to explore that
because I've always been interested in
investing pre-product hunt
I don't think it was the right direction
and this is where I personally just
don't think that was the right that
would have been the right outcome it
would have actually changed product hunt
dramatically into a much different type
of business and kind of be more like
angelist potentially than again that's
what I was saying is like there was a
way you could have from your starting
point could have actually been angelist
if you went down that path um and so
again I'm not even saying it's the right
one there's also like Kickstarter you
could have been like oh let's help
people like you know imagine that you
could remember those experiments people
did where if enough people took an
action it would unlock launching do you
remember that there was like a hype
machine did hype machine did like a
bunch of sites like 10 years ago did
this stuff but
um you would create Collective action
around people's launches and either help
them actually sell products or monetize
their products or get their initial user
base and I know you do beta testers
right that's pretty cool aren't you
already doing yeah we we've experimented
with some things and then we sort of
built a tool for people to collect beta
users like emails and and that kind of
thing cuz like there's ways that instead
of taking equity in companies you still
could have provided did like pretty deep
Services deeper than just click on my
website and maybe sign up and like I
think people would have happily paid for
like for sure so anyway it's yeah it
doesn't matter now but like I'm just
like super fascinated on thinking
through just what a great thing you had
and all the ways like like I've been in
silon Valley a long time and it's just
like these little micro decisions that
is a difference between you know
Facebook being Facebook and Myspace or
like sites we haven't even thought of
like I don't know tagged remember that
and like high five and like I remember
all these like I remember the founders
for all those companies and like they
were there we were you know um but
little micro decisions um have really
huge effects over time yeah and I'm
fascinated by that and I think part of
it this is a challenge going back to the
money thing too when you when you do
raise a lot of money and you feel like
you have infinite Runway uh you should
treat it like you don't and truthfully
there's some things that that I I
prioritized on the team because I wanted
it myself like some redesign work that
we did which redesigns are often times a
trap like there's times when you want to
do redesign work but often times it's
realistically not going to change your
numbers all that much and especially
with something like what we built where
we have a community of people like
people really don't care if the upot
button looks a little bit shinier like
they're going to use it or not because
of the content like the conversation of
the people there remember all the Dig
redesigns yeah yeah was rough yeah
although dig dig I don't blame them for
the the 4.0 I think release was the one
that really had a problem um I think
that direction was uh directionally like
intuitive it was moving it was when
Twitter was taking off and like how do
you build something that's even more um
accessible and builds more um retention
Loops through following and that type of
thing I think there's some good ideas
there but it's hard communities are
really hard too because oh yeah you know
they don't like change they don't they
don't and we've made changes that the
communities has been upset about and
some cases we reverted some cases we let
them get used to it yeah but I think
this is a very real problem like a lot
of venture back companies don't have
that same sense of urgency that you know
like Indie haacker type companies have
they're like Hey listen I could work on
a redesign for the next month or I could
like optimize my sales funnel and like
make you know 100,000 more dollars so
now that you guys are within
angelist you could be a little more
slack maybe so like how are you creating
that urgency like what are you focusing
on right now yeah so we have so last
year we have three kpis actually that we
measure uh revenue is one of them that
was our number one priority last year
not because we are running out of money
it's because we just want to build a
model that can scale and cover our
expenses and so we're we hit
profitability last year second metric
was just user growth how do we get more
people using product hunt and the third
is community contributions that's
measured by the number of people up
voting commenting contributing and that
that's important because it's basically
the measurement of Health if we have
nobody uploading then we have nothing so
we got to make sure that's that's good
and this year we're switching it around
revenues is not the number one priority
we're switching towards user growth and
we're focusing on kind of a couple
different themes one of them one of them
I can't share uh too many specifics on
but it's a lot about focusing on how do
we help people find the best products or
the products they should be using so
product has always been about the new
products come here open up the website
you discover things that you never would
have searched for because they didn't
exist yesterday and it's kind of a place
to get like a fire hose of new cool
stuff but a lot of people in fact
probably more people in the world have a
greater desire to find the best products
for specific things and it could be
something like I I switch from Android
to iPhone you know what apps should I be
downloading and using and exploring some
of it might be I'm starting a new
company what's the best Analytics tool
for this budget for these needs um so
really focusing on on this and building
out like a true product graph is kind of
what we're moving towards and so that's
one theme let's let's solve for that use
case and when by the way when we build
products we we have a pretty good
process down where we'll have usually
one engineer to start with on it and
they they drive the project forward
alongside like Julie or Dan on the
design side and so we're able to like do
a lot of projects at once which some
people might say is a bad thing but for
us it works really well the way we're
set up and so that's one thing we have
going on then we have going back to
maker communities we want to focus more
on the social networking kind of side of
product hunt and and technology and
making itself and we've kind of
experimented and dabbled with some of
this but we're we're starting to hone in
on something that I think is is going to
work we'll see if it does uh around
virtual co-working and I don't think
I've used those words publicly at all
but there's this the people who are most
engaged on product are working on side
projects they're Freelancers they're
remote workers and they're just really
curious and eager and they have desire
to one meet other people like them get
help from other people that are maybe
have a different skill set whether
design or engineering and and also
there's an aspect of loneliness too if
you're working on a project by yourself
like and especially if you're not in
Silicon Valley or like a tech Hub like
where do you go and so we want to build
out ways for people to do all those
things on product hunt and really
support this like future maker kind of
ecosystem going forward yeah I see uh y
see applications along those lines of
basically remote work is a big Trend and
people are trying to think about tools
and like any there's a bunch of ways to
attack the problem but for sure I'm very
familiar with excitement around making
it easier better faster for folks that
are working remotely all over the world
to work together and collaborate yeah
the tooling I mean we got slack but
tooling wise there's not a lot of not
much I mean there's not much Ryan and I
both talked about this we're both in
long-distance relationships and he was
like tweeting about it like what are the
solutions people are using and like it's
super hacky WhatsApp FaceTime kind of
stuff but that's it yeah yeah yeah and
there should be like this uh the other
realization is I think some people
forget is most people also don't have
large following online whether it's
Twitter or Facebook or whatever and when
you're building something and you want
feedback at best you ask your friends
and your friends give you really
terrible positive advice cuz they don't
want to hurt your feelings and so
there's there's like a greater need
among this giant audience of people to
to have some sort of support network
while they're building and exploring
yeah so I was curious about this so
there are a bunch of questions basically
people asking for advice on like what
makes a su a successful product on
product hunt and like did you guys ever
consider going in that direction like
more educational cont content for for
your users yeah we I mean we have FAQs
and like how-tos and things like that
but we've never never really gone deep
into the educational side because I
think this kind of goes back to what
we're saying like there's many different
things that we could build for product
hunt and as much as I'd love to help
educate people it's not I think a core
Focus for us um but yeah I think the
general advice really when it come to
like people ask me all the time how
what's the best way to launch a product
and sometimes it's just simple advice
like make sure the imagery is really
clear the tagline is really clear um you
know Bounce It Off a few people that
don't know you or don't know about your
product and speak like a human not like
a marketer you know what I'd love to
hear about is an example of your
favorite company that's ever launched on
product hunt that you're most proud of
almost like that you helped enable her
success and maybe the reverse but I
realize you can't but just like what's
an example of no one specific but just
how someone can get to number one on
product hunt and have a good launch and
then actually like they didn't make so
many people want and they churned
everybody and like what you've learned
and internalized about someone with a
great launch that in it sticks and they
really go off into the stratosphere
versus kind of like oh people checked
out my silly thing and then there's
nothing there like I'd love to hear your
thoughts on that there's kind of a
couple there's two different things that
come to mind uh one more recent actually
and this isn't a startup actually it's
not a company but it's there there's a
number of um kind of self-described like
Indie makers or or people who are just
eager to build things not necessarily to
make money sometimes they do but
sometimes it's just to build things and
show it show it off and like be creative
and explore and we do this thing called
Golden Kitty awards every every year
which kind of nominates different
products in different categories and we
have one category for like maker of the
year and we sort of take a look at all
the up votes and some data from the past
year to determine who that is and um and
I I apologize I might be forgetting his
name but it's Andre if I'm not mistaken
in Europe he he won maker of the year
and this is a a younger guy who learned
a code a few years ago uh launched in
his first product a couple years ago on
product hunt after learning about 30 or
60 days uh and then since then he's just
he's almost like he's got the bug he's
got the bug to build and I I like to
think that at least prodent helped in
some way in giving him feedback because
otherwise when you build something you
spend all this time and no one uses it
no one sees it it doesn't mean that they
have to like use it forever but like
getting some sort of feedback loops is
so important when you're building
something he he now as since built and
launched tons and tons of different
products and and I was happy to see like
he one maker of the year and he even
recorded the video put it on Twitter and
was like thanks everybody like so happy
um so there's like the sort of
heartwarming like it's great to have a
tiny tiny piece of uh in supporting
these like future well these makers or
maybe future founders of companies um
but then going to a company example one
that that really sticks to mind is
mircat uh do you remember mircat back in
day course yeah so I've gotten to know
Ben I actually saw him last weekend um
the CEO of mircat now house party and
mirat was such a an awesome it it it
tick so many boxes that were like
perfect in terms of the the messaging
was really clear it was I think the
tagline was something along the lines of
uh uh broadcast live video to your
Twitter followers so it's very specific
actually and the product design was was
built for leveraging the Twitter graph
which I think today still is
underutilized actually and quickly it
Rose to problem like blew up everyone
was using it for a little while and the
the problem was that the product itself
was not return
and you know most people are really bad
including myself at live video it's just
really hard to create good content and
to watch live video you have to watch it
when it's live too so there's like all
these challenges with the product when
it comes to retention and being
something that works but what they did
realize kind of within that is some
people are sort of hacking it and using
mirat to hang out with friends and
that's what ultimately like inspired
house party which is an app you open it
up and you and your friends immediately
are in like video chat and you can just
hang out and chat and it's solving this
like underlying desire of connection and
and being together with like people
remote and and your friends maybe back
at home or your girlfriend or whoever
and um so that was just like an
interesting example because it blew up
immediately and and uh yet at the same
time it required Ben and the team to be
thoughtful and like honest with
themselves like they could have run they
could have run out of money and run the
company into the ground if they were
persistent and and um thinking that this
would work that mirat would work as it
is today instead they had to change
that's really smart like and that's a
great example we were talking about
earlier of like
knowing where that decision point is and
it they didn't it wasn't like a hard
pivot where they did something radically
different but clearly yeah you know I'm
really curious now dton you've probably
read like what 10,000 applications I've
read a lot of applic an infinite amount
all of the applications um you know I'm
just kind of connecting the dots now but
like both of you guys basically like
review products all year round and I'm
curious like how much time do you
actually spend on product hunt in like
in your YC application reading mind like
are you filtering through it in the same
way or are you just curious about oh
this is a cool side project I'll try it
out I think the most important thing
that I look at is how serious the
founders are and if they really made
something and showed it to people and so
it's almost like it doesn't matter if
the product is good so many people that
apply aspirationally maybe want to build
something someday possibly yeah but for
the people that are serious enough to
really make something and be brave
enough to to show it to other people and
be willing to take all of the like you
know it's really scary to do that you
know and so when you see someone that's
actually made something and they're
willing to share it with the world and
they they show that commitment but
they're serious about it I I'm very much
I'm paying attention to you and I care
less about like the scale of the revenue
like I was saying earlier I care less
about if the design is really good like
those things are nice but man if the
difference between someone that's
serious and not serious is all
difference in the world does that make
and so how do you evaluate that in
applications how do you know if they're
serious you can see if they've done
something like again like do you even do
you have a prototype do you have a first
user have you made a dollar of Revenue
like again it's very it depends on the
type of company it is but you can see
the difference between hey I want to
raise money before I work on this
yeah that's a certain sort of thing and
that's not really our our necessarily
our bread and butter um and then the
people that you can tell that they're
going to work on their dream no matter
what with or without you and that you
can hopefully help them in some way and
again I would put you in you did it like
no one like no one told you hey you
should go make product hunt you should
make this email list like you weren't
trying I don't think trying to please
investors you were just trying to do
something you thought was cool yeah and
like that was the kernel of goodness
that you had
right like you figure that on your own
without authority figures telling you to
do it and like that's really special and
that's a huge signal yeah one one thing
I've been thinking a lot about is I I
was fortunate in that I I'd been working
at a previous company for 3 years after
3 years I was like I got to I got to do
something different I gave notice that
turned into a part-time role actually so
cut my salary in half work 20 hours a
week that gave me plenty of time for
product hun so I was lucky in that I I
could financially support myself as I
was tinkering and building and a lot of
people just don't especially in San
Francisco and I've been thinking more
about this Challenge and maybe it's I'd
be curious if YC is thinking about this
but like how do you how do you give
people that opportunity to quit their
job and give them 6 months or 12 months
whatever the time is to do that cuz you
know you can do a lot of nights and
weekends and I think people
underestimate that but uh there's also
some people just have challenges in like
having enough time to truly see
something through without quitting their
job yeah so in startup school which is
the online course thing that we have
anyone could participate you definitely
don't need to be full-time um there's
even for a small percentage of people
that are really serious we give them
grants um I think this is all on our
blog but like there
how much do you give 10,000 10 grand
yeah to everyone or just certain I think
we did 100 companies yeah oh W so you
know again we can't can't be for
everyone but those are people where they
were really serious they were really
working hard and we you know um that
could be really helpful to them and
again the whole point of startup school
was like even for people that haven't
quit their job it gives you a chance to
be serious and structured in your
thinking put on your calendar and make
progress there's so many people that
want to start a startup and whether or
not they quit their jobs they never like
begin yeah well I mean that's that's
kind of what you were alluding to like a
lot of people man like would never even
think about I should go part-time I
should go 20 hours a week like a lot of
people never get the confidence and
never feel like they're good enough to
do the thing so like startup school is
awesome there but for you what like what
motivated you to be like eh you know
what I can do part-time I can make this
work it was it was more that I I just
knew I just knew deep in my heart that I
need to do something different cuz I was
I felt like I wasn't learning uh and I
love love the company love the team but
it you know there's certain moments I
think in everyone's career people who
have worked with me you know that I've
transitioned out you know it's been a a
good transition because I saw like I get
it like I know why you're leaving and I
know why it's maybe not a good place for
you anymore so for me I just I forced
myself and I I I initially was just
going to leave entirely and not do
parttime and I was like I have a little
bit of money saved I'll figure it out
and uh maybe I was a little bit I don't
know naive in that sense but it did work
out and um you know there's a reason why
I actually named the fund I started
weekend fund though too because I I
think a lot of amazing companies and and
amazing things can be built on a weekend
if you can afford the time and I think a
lot of people tend to now I don't want
to uh uh some people have family some
people have Financial burdens there's
like things like that that certainly are
debilitating but I think for a lot of
people there are no excuses not to be
working on the weekend and like trying
and making some progress yeah well if
you want to do a startup and not
everyone like it's not not for everybody
but like if you're if you're curious you
have to start and man does that screen
out a lot of people if they don't like
start yeah yeah yeah yeah and and the
progress too there's something about as
as I speak with companies and look at uh
you now from an investor side a little
bit progress is like everything and just
even if it's it doesn't have to be you
know 50% month- over month growth but
I've invested in companies after
following them for even just two or
three weeks have given me more
confidence based on what they're
shipping and how they're interacting
with their users and those types of
small micro like day-to-day um uh
interactions uh really matter a lot yeah
I mean I think that's a great place to
wrap it up but uh yeah thanks for coming
in guys yeah thanks having me cool
appreciate it